the blood of house L will always bind us
together
[Music]
hey everybody whole bunch of Justice
League stuff happening I figured it was
time to start talking about the Superman
prequel TV series Krypton they have the
teaser out they've revealed that
Brainiac dooms a bunch of big characters
are coming and they calling it a
terminator version of a Superman story
so if that doesn't blow your mind
already that basically means they're
jumping around in time and somebody will
be messing with Superman's timeline but
if you're finding me for the first time
be sure to subscribe to get everything
there's a Justice League ticket giveaway
I'm still doing to all explain at the
end of the video you know at the kind of
the heart of it is this there is a
conspiracy from I wish I could but I am
I can't say who from present-day earth
2017 and there's you know traveling back
in time to Krypton of 200 years ago and
the conspiracies to prevent the birth of
Superman so that's what the stakes of
the show are really about so it's less
about a look back at this period of time
that's in the past but it it's about now
the shows the shows are about the
present there is a bit of a terminator a
bit of a terminator kind of way we're
approaching this which is we immediately
just want to kind of you know really
pull the rug out from under the the
mythology of Krypton so that by the end
of the pilot you're like Oh everything I
thought I knew about where this was
gonna go and what what's supposed to
happen that's not happening anymore and
and this isn't just to look back it's
kind of the past and the present
colliding and the stakes are kind of the
whole I did a video earlier this year
but they've since changed the show
enough do they ask people to take their
trailer videos down which is a really
weird thing to do but whatever like you
saw in that teaser it's supposed to
premiere next year they didn't say
exactly when but I think it's supposed
to be in the spring but they just
confirmed that Brainiac would be coming
to the series we learned about Adam
Strange they have full-blown doomsday
coming hawkwoman
and then without completely spoiling
everything they said other big comic
book characters would be coming on from
the Superman mythos so if you have no
idea what's going on you're like wait a
minute there's a Superman TV show I
didn't know about this
what's happening is is originally the
idea was is they were gonna do a TV show
about Superman's grandfather called seg
L played by this actor here they shot a
pilot there was a trailer earlier this
year there's a bootleg version that went
around but then they took those all down
they had originally planned to air that
pilot episode during Comic Con but I
think what happened is is they went back
to the board with the series they
retooled a bunch of things they recast a
couple of the actors and I think it
changed enough that they didn't want to
show people what it looked like because
the actual show will look so much
different but I know a lot of you are
like well wait a minute if they're doing
Superman's grandfather and this is
supposed to be about a hundred years
before Krypton was blown up so jor-el
hasn't been born yet in fact his
grandfather is like a young man he's
like Clark Kent
during Smallville age but when you hear
characters like hawkwoman and Adam
strange you're like wait a minute
they're from the modern era how could
they be on a TV series that said a
hundred years in the past
so they confirmed this is probably one
of the changes they made during the
course of this year is that the TV show
will take place during multiple time
periods so sort of the core mystery of
the TV series is if somebody has a plot
to erase Superman's legacy in present
day so they do something in the past in
hawkwoman
in Adam Strange find out about it it
starts off this big conspiracy that
throws them between the past and the
present so before this all started I
think originally it was just intended to
be a straight up Superman prequel and it
would always take place in the past but
I do like the new idea like people are
trying to get rid of Superman in present
day so you go back and you try to do
something to his family in the past but
I saw a lot of you in my timeline
recently asking about the logic of
Brainiac because he's a clue and
artificial intelligence in yeah there's
a bunch of different versions of him in
the DC Universe but he's mainly thought
of as a present-day Superman villain so
if you're wondering how Brainiac can
appear in the past you just have to
remember that he's ancient it took him a
long time to evolve
like for instance Brainiac 5 he's a
member of the Legion of super-heroes in
the 30 and 31st century so I would say
that we're gonna see the origins of
Brainiac but because it's a time-travel
show we might be seeing future versions
of Brainiac that have come back into the
past to try and change things but there
too many questions all we know is that
this is the actor that will be playing
Brainiac so it'll be a human form
version of the character whichever
version of him we see whether it's
Brainiac one two three whichever one the
other big thing is doomsday like what's
going on with doomsday in the past now
he was created by the Kryptonian
underworld so we might get to see some
scientists experimenting with proto
versions of doomsday as we know him in
present day but because of the way the
doomsday works he's effectively timeless
in the way that Superman is you almost
can't kill him you can fire him into the
Sun but he can almost regenerate from a
single drop of blood Lobo style so I
think the big question here is is like
when will these characters pop up are
they going to be the present versions
are they going to be the versions in the
past I think when you hear really cool
characters are coming on like that
they're just gonna let them have fun
with it so we'll probably see multiple
different versions of each of the
characters with exception to Superman I
think the idea of Superman on the TV
show will probably be a little bit
different than what you've seen before
the last big TV version of Superman we
saw was when Tyler hoechlin did it on
Supergirl
the TV show is supposed to be a way more
hardcore version of the mythos so think
of it as being more in the tone of the
movies which is why this is more of a DC
movie prequel than it is a DC TV prequel
but here are the creators talking a
little bit about the TV series back at
comic-con so it it gives us a kind of a
blank slate really to work with there
are things that we tie in to existing
Canon but we've kind of got our own
little corner of the DC Universe to play
with which is you know fantastic it
quickly becomes a series where a couple
of things become true one it is not a
story about 200 years ago it is actually
a story about the president everything
that's happening in our show affects now
and so there could be some time-travel
involved but we can't confirm or deny
but truthfully it becomes what the here
now and that up ends the story and
changes the future to the point where
we're not sure what is going to happen
to Krypton we really just wanted
immediately to reset the stakes and
where people think they know about the
origins of Superman
what Krypton is and what Krypton's
destiny is so that's all thrown into
question immediately when the show
begins so let me know in the comments
what do you guys think of the idea of a
hardcore Superman TV show that jumps
around in time and gets to do some of
the biggest characters but it's not
necessarily connected to the DC TV shows
so like all the characters you see here
like the hawk woman that you see on this
TV show will not be the hawk woman that
you saw on legends of tomorrow but it's
just an example of them doing a more
hardcore spin on DC TV like when the
Titans TV show comes everyone's talking
about Nightwing I just did a video about
it that will also be more hardcore than
the TV shows you've seen so far which I
think people have been asking for I
think there's room for more hardcore
stuff as long as it's on the right
network and that's kind of what Syfy is
going for there is that Justice League
ticket giveaway that's going on right
now all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on the video
I'll announce a winner the next time I
post Justice League that'll probably be
later this week and they just dropped a
whole bunch of new stuff while you wait
for everything click here for my Thor
Ragnarok post-credit scene and you can
click here for my arrow Deathstroke
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight